you don't want anyone else to get hurt
you got to give me the shield
you don't want to do this yeah
how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder and
as you just saw we have seen a new
falcon and the winter soldier tv spot a
very rare tv spot that hasn't really
been circulating around tv so it makes
us wonder if this was actually supposed
to be released or not
but either way we have the footage and
it definitely shows us a lot of what's
going to happen in episode 5 and it also
reveals some other things not shown in
this trailer but shown in previous
trailers as well
now i'll issue a spoiler alert although
we did just watch a leaked
tv spot but this tv spot did give us a
bit of clarity of how the next episode
is going to go down
now this tv spot actually shows us
several things
it looks like it does show us the power
broker and it looks like it shows us
another character that is really really
hard to make out but perhaps most
importantly it shows us the fight
between
sam bucky and john walker now only a few
days ago marvel studios actually
released their mid-season trailer for
the falcon and the winter soldier and we
got that epic scene between falcon bucky
and john walker
[Music]
we don't want anyone else to get hurt
you don't want to do this
yeah we do now before when we didn't
have as much context we thought that
they may not
actually fight here and they may team up
because we saw john walker with the
shield
in other scenes in the trailer and we
haven't yet seen those scenes
which means they're coming in future
episodes however in this league tv spot
it does in fact show that they are going
to fight and the biggest part about this
is they're fighting over the shield
they're not actually fighting to stop
john walker from going about and doing
more harm to the flag smashers they're
fighting him because they want
the shield back they want steve rogers's
shield
john walker has disgraced their best
friend's shield and
symbol and it's time for them to take it
back now this actually goes
against what sam said in episode two
talking about
running up on a man beating him up and
taking the shield let's take the shield
sound
let's take the shield and do this
ourselves we can't just run up on a man
beat him up and tape
however this was before john walker did
all of the things that he did
this was before he said stay the hell
out of my way it's before he messed up
the conversation with sam and carly
and before he brutally beat somebody to
death in front of a lot of people
not to mention sam has really been
contemplating what the shield
means to him and clearly since he has
decided that it's time to take back the
shield
it means a lot to him after all steve
did give him the shield
and decided that he was to be the next
captain america
and then the government went and gave
the shield to john walker who is clearly
not fit to handle the shield
at least that's how sam and bucky see it
so since in the scene we know the shield
still has blood on it this scene is
going to be directly after what happened
last in the falcon and the winter
soldier episode 4.
john walker beats the flag smasher to
death goes away into this warehouse area
and sam and bucky follow since they were
with him and watched him do it
they decide that this is the line john
walker has crossed the line and they're
not gonna let him have the shield
anymore
so they confront john walker and as we
hear him say in the trailer
sam says we don't want anybody else to
get hurt you gotta give me the shield
there might be a little bit more
dialogue like john walker saying no
i am captain america this is my shield
in which sam and bucky say we don't want
to but we will take it from you and then
john walker will say
you don't want to do this bucky looks up
and says yeah we do
and from here we're probably going to
have a ridiculously cool fight scene
probably much like the one in captain
america civil war where it's bucky and
steve versus tony
only this time bucky has a new partner
falcon and they're going to be fighting
a
makeshift captain america and judging by
some scenes that we saw
in the mid-season trailer that marvel
studios put out a few days ago
john walker loses he probably gets his
butt kicked in fact we have seen some
leaked photos of him where his arm is in
a sling
now this may happen from the flax
smashers but it probably is going to
happen from bucky or sam
yes john walker is a super soldier now
but bucky is as well
and he has a vibranium arm not to
mention falcon really knows how to fight
and
use his gear and of course it's two
against one so
john walker doesn't really stand a
chance i mean he got beat by people who
weren't even super soldiers granted the
dora milaje
are incredibly awesome but now john
walker has to fight one super soldier in
an incredibly trained
avenger so he's going to lose against
the two of them and the two of them are
going to take his shield
now how do we know this well it's
because of some of those scenes in the
other trailer
we see john walker walking down the
street with a new
shield now at first it did look like the
original shield but if you take a look
closely it does have some differences on
the star
we can see some markings here some lines
that aren't on the original shield the
one shield that we've been seeing this
whole entire series
so it's very possible that the us
government somewhere had a back-up
shield
after all wakanda did open its resources
aka vibranium
up to the world and after civil war
steve rogers and t'challa became pretty
close
wakanda took bucky in got rid of his
brainwashing and
wakanda fought against thanos it makes
total sense that wakanda would give the
us government some vibranium so they
could have made another shield and i
hope this is the case i hope it's not
classic marvel trying to throw us off
with different trailers and tv spots
they are known for doing that
but again it doesn't really seem like
john walker could beat sam
and bucky at the same time and he
probably couldn't beat either one of
them
one on one and since we have seen sam
with the shield
in many different tv spots and trailers
it's safe to assume that they do get the
shield
and since john walker is seen in the
trailer in a new scene where he has his
shield
it's probably a different shield which
means we could be getting a shield
versus shield battle a battle between
the current
captain america and the person who
should have been
captain america and that could give us a
similar fight to what we saw in avengers
end game where steve fought steve when
they went back in time
that is america's ass
now if this all ends up happening that
means that the american government
probably pardoned john walker for
beating the crap out of that flag
smasher
it doesn't look like he's going to have
that many repercussions from what he
did after all the flag smashers are
terrorists and they did kill lamar
hoskins aka battle star
so in some people's eyes this may be
justified john walker simply killed a
terrorist so they send john walker back
out there and they send them out with a
new
shield and that's how it looks like it's
going to go down in episode
5. now as i mentioned and as you saw in
this tv spot there are two
new characters that we can see but
unfortunately the footage isn't that
clear and we can't really make out the
actors but we do know it's two
men now one of these is most likely the
power broker we've been hearing a
ton about the power broker hopefully he
finally makes an appearance
plus we heard that there's another cameo
coming one that is not the power broker
played by an academy award-winning actor
and that actor could be one of the two
people in this scene
now in this scene where there's a big
round table this could be the power
broker it seems like a well set up
organization
unfortunately i can't see who this
person could be at the same time this
could be the grc
as you can see what's going on in this
scene here is it's being
hacked all of the tv screens in the
background are being hacked so it could
be the flag smashers hacking into the
grc
this other new character we see that
seems to be in a parking garage walking
away from the car
could be the power broker or he could
simply be an entirely new character they
introduce
and again sadly i can't make out who
this actor is but if anybody can
identify one of these two actors be sure
to let me know in the comments down
below or you can tweet at me
on twitter and in the meantime let me
know what you think about this upcoming
battle between sam
bucky and john walker don't forget to
subscribe so you can stay up to date on
all things mcu and check out the
description down below and the pin
comment for details about my giveaway
i'm giving away a falcon in the winter
soldier captain america shield
don't forget to like the video and for
live updates you can follow me on
instagram or twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof